hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3. we're coming into the final
stretch so we're gonna need to really
focus in here and not stick around
this is my serious face that means i'm
totally in it to win it
oh okay i get it now i can do the second
con
confirmation thingy convoluted that i
can do that
i'm gonna do that okay so i need to make
these all quissy quasi
chrissy quasi
i'm gonna make them quiz quast
because i'm from new jersey
and then those other ones need to come
down one
there we go
we're good
let's actuate this thumb [ __ ]
get it done
all righty then
that looks fancy
what did that do i am
oh
danic
no
i know you think you're doing the right
thing but you are wrong isaac you have
to let me turn off the machine
i don't think so
with a big surprise
oh
that doesn't sound good
it doesn't sound like i want it to
happen
is your big surprise
a nuke of some sort
oh get away from me i'm a dragon
you're son of a [ __ ]
you thought you could
oh off i go into space
too late
you're alive
i escaped the delivery too they called
me
they're gonna call you up in the ah
let go of me shut up heretic
i have the codex danic if you want it
you have to find me
no i won't
you're heading to the machine
and when you get there i'll be waiting
i knew ellie was still alive they
couldn't kill her off like that
yes
joey's boobs are okay i mean nellie's
okay
gotta get to hey
miss me you missed your one shot bro
hey what's this [ __ ] [ __ ]
ow
thank you for having your head explode
can i have this thank you
can i have this
go half off i can't really throw that
that far i wish i could
no one wants to come play with me
well fine
i didn't need you anyway
screw you and all you care about i'm
going over here now
i screw them no no time to waste gotta
get going oh hey where do you [ __ ]
come from
thank you
guys just standing there doing nothing
what a useless bunch
what
okay now what
three receptacles three statues
three markings easy enough what's the
final step uh seems pretty obvious to me
bruh
i gotta go grab the symbols out of all
three of these doodads and jam them into
the whatchamacallit
ah
boom
and you guys suck
wait
that one's coming from behind me oh i've
detected you a long way to it ow you're
a [ __ ]
ah i shall have a shotgun
oh what's that
you can't get me
i am apparently bad at aiming
stupid light getting in my way
damn it i'm too proud to be held back by
stupid lights
oh another one
jesus you're coming out of the freaking
walls
i guess these are all the reinforcements
jesus
leave me alone for a couple where'd you
come from where did he come from
seriously
i'm gonna stomp the [ __ ] you where the
[ __ ] did that guy come from
a baloney shoot that over there two
points
jace's pack i'll take that
ah
head splosion give me that
oops
need to do another
anybody else want to step while i'm over
here
anybody else
anybody huh
yeah that's right that's what i thought
what i thought
all right anyway i'm just need to check
to make sure yeah i used a lot of med
packs on that for some reason
i'll go with the medium ones i always if
i get the big ones i always overuse them
so
i wish it was more intelligent about the
way that they were used but it's
not so oh well
i'll just have to make do
what oh crap ah caps locks was on good
thing i know about that trick boosh
i boost you over there where i need you
and then i will
assemble this puzzle relax so easily
okay so
this is a
this one's a oh
no that's backwards sorry i got that
wrong
oh okay
well that is easy
you think they make more puzzle elements
than just three but okay whatever easy
all right carver another door just
opened up we got to be close to the
control center for the codex we've done
everything else serrano's set to do
i'm heading in
i'm headed in
nobody can stop isaac clark
no man
no necromorph
nobody
oh another divi duty
thingy i'm a bobber my [ __ ]
harpoon in the yeah you know what i'm
talking about
oh
fancy
oh that dog that hurt yeah that hurt
okay how do i i can't jump upwards duh
hey stop that
okay gotta stasis this
just be very careful about where your
whoa
stasis hot piss i say stood way too
early
mommy
my bad
sorry i'll sneak through as soon as it
come on clear out
clear
you're stupid
i'm afraid to touch it because i know
it'll get there we go okay
now we're
ah
of course of course of course
of course
there's an audio message here that i
missed anyway
yeah i don't have time to listen to you
i wish you would talk louder
i know your knees busted and all
okay let's try this again with less
failure
can't believe i i can't believe i did
that why did i stasis that so early why
did i try to go when i knew it was going
to come out of stasis all these things
are perfectly logical ways that they
have killed me that i just kind of
ignore
and this is a weird design for a
building just just saying
and save it now
yes
that's perfect good job me thanks me i
know i'm too proud
so appropriate
god my pronus levels
through the roof
need more protosterone
damn so
you're a little faster ain't your
bluetooth
[ __ ] you did it again oh pat ah you
[ __ ] flames i'm trying to get away
oh fine i'll go you stay there
stay
these sons are [ __ ]
ah
it's the most dangerous one yet
okay
go go go please climb faster bruh
i use once again i've used many medkits
on this silliness
like what is the point of the design
just have flames shooting out of a wall
you know
for structural reasons
all right here we are oh i didn't get to
press the e button
oh this looks final where did you come
from carver
are you betraying me carver
don't betray me bruh
we've been through too much bri
okay here we go carter
isaac don't do it don't listen to him
give me the codex and you can have her
back no
isaac you know what's at stake okay
everybody calm down okay danic give me
the codex
or i will kill her no
isaac
what are you doing
you got a second chance if he turns off
the machine we're all dead
her
us
everyone don't let it all go dark isaac
there's more than one kind of right
i've done it
i finally done it
the darkness isn't in there
let the evolution
begin
when i finish this
it's all going down everything
you have to go no
you two get out of here go back to earth
space tell them what we found i'm
staying that's all i got left you can't
stop it carver
not without me
i'm the marker killer remember isaac
i turned my back on the world because i
was afraid of what needed to be done
ellie
i'm not afraid anymore
there's a shuttle over there
i want you to take it head for home
don't come back for me
we both know i'm not going home
um
holy crap okay this is it guys we are
finishing the fight right now
convergence
vortex it is
yes so let's get this done
for ellie
the moon that thing is the moon
that moon is alive
jesus
and one of my criticisms about dead
space too is it didn't end with a
gigantic boss
holy hell i guess it can't get much more
gigantic than that
jesus
please tell me i fight that thing on a
1v1
sniper match
where did all these weird markers come
from the whole thing is pulsing i mean
they must like these alien structure
is totally designed just to collapse
just the right way
so that i can make it out of here or
make it through here to the end
strategically placed supply drops
hello what are you doing here
you shouldn't be here it's dangerous
where'd you go oh there you are
no thank you thank you
thanks but no thanks
i've got places to be
i've got worlds to save you know isaac
clark why
where did you come from
thank you don't have time gotta get out
of
here
whoa
where'd you guys come from
thank you
all right that was the only one i needed
to take care of
moving forward at breakneck pace or not
maybe not whoa where'd you come from
buddy
nope oh no you don't
why isn't your back a sensitive spot
like in the other thing
come on die already jesus there we go
ah [ __ ] all the supplies just went up
into space
okay where am i going here i guess i
just gotta kill this thing
come on
thank you that's it
there we go
i hope i got enough ammo i i didn't
exactly stock up
come on
bring it [ __ ]
you want to mess with isaac clark isaac
clark will take you down with me
let's do this oh this might be exactly
what i was hoping for
[ __ ] it i'll save my ammo
all right that didn't count
take two
take two
i don't know why i thought i could go
right
no one saw
anything
ah get away get away get away get away
you're all dumb i do not like you
i can only aim directly forward
kind of inconvenient but i'm okay
oh god i loved it ah
you saw the [ __ ] i didn't even see
you coming
ah oh come on i didn't even see that
coming
[ __ ]
okay that never happened
that didn't happen
where the frick did that thing come from
oh stupid okay whatever
trying to get this done
eloquently
and you know with
skill and class and style
damn and i literally can't aim at those
things before they start releasing there
oh maybe if i shoot him they release
their doodads that's probably i should
not shoot oh no wait they hurt if i
don't shoot them
okay let's go let's go now come on now
avoiding the debris that is flying that
i did not see because i did clark was in
the way
is this where we're landing or is this
just where we're going through
yep
all right
it's weird i'm just flying on these
little bits of crap i was that close and
i got
i was stupid
i was stupid that was stupid let's not
no one saw anything everybody forget
that the last five minutes just happened
by the bye
and this was a much better let's play
where i played with skill
and determination
thank you
oh is there zero gravity here or
something
because things just seem to be kind of
flying upwards
hey you
what's up beautiful
how are you doing
oh
well thank you for that
carrying on long and strong
what oh this way
don't go that way
they're giving me plenty of med kits
which i am very happy about hey
i haven't seen one of you the entire
game
hey
that was a spitter or a spewer or
a throwy upper oh hi
excuse me go away please i got business
you guys are tough these particular ones
are kind of tough
anyway yeah i haven't seen a a a puker
this entire game what's going on here
i hear some yeah
where have they been
yeah
i mean there were those evolved types of
pukers whatever they're called i forget
what they're really called there were
the different types that were in the
game but i never saw an actual dead
space 2 poker puker
you know a puker oh this way okay
i'm almost at the end guys this will
probably be the last bench before i get
there yep last bench and suit kiosk
right before the end
i probably shouldn't have done that
thank you all right let's see how my
supplies are doing stock up for the
final battle
definitely need more ammo got plenty of
med kits surprisingly
uh how are we doing on stasis packs
let's get rid of these small ones
they're just a waste of space let me get
more stasis packs just in case they're
not exactly expensive
full six
and
i'll do it i think maybe one more medium
and
yeah i'll do it that ought to do it i'm
stocked locked and ready to rock
all right i'm fully upgraded on my suit
i believe i don't need it anyway
my armor is definitely updated so i'm
good blood moon i am here
this is it
ow
okay
all right
let's do this oh it looked like the suit
isaac's suit was pretty effed up
okay we're okay whoa hi ah
oh man
hey buddy i'm gonna shoot the piss out
of you
get ready blood moon i got one gun
that's all i need for you
it's nice how these things just line up
oh so perfectly
hey isn't that what is that
is that the machine or a part of it
anyway
perfect
perfect landing
eyeball big and yellow i'm gonna shoot
it
hi
hey
you ugly
i don't mean to be insulting but you
ugly
you can't have man
yes
we gotta kill that thing
there's not enough ammo in the world
we'll have to make stuff up
but there's markers floating all around
me i can use this tk charging plate and
throw them as well
okay
okay i need a bit more whoa what is that
supposed to be
what are those supposed to be
oh i see what they're supposed to be
well i don't know what these things are
but they're kind of freaky okay give me
a marker baby haberski god
suck it [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you think you got
you got nothing
am i shooting at that green watch out
of giant chumps
rockets i see it
it i of
come on turn your head [ __ ]
i'm uh hey i gotta take care of these
guys
oh what's that you wanted that oh sorry
i just thought you were you were you oh
huh oh you wanted these spikes i'm not
bad
sorry
am i supposed to shoot that thing maybe
i don't know
oh
guy looks a little unhappy
might need to change things up for him
hey
thank you
easy
i am happy that there are so many
markers just lying around everywhere
hey buddy come bring a little closer get
a good look at me hey
i'm like freaking super saiyan up in
this [ __ ]
no just give me your [ __ ] whoa
give me
give me that
no thank you go away thank you goodbye
ah fun in hell anything else
i'm full on that
got another marker ready to fire
seriously i'm wondering why the machine
is there am i supposed to hit that
i don't think i'm actually doing
anything to that machine there
not that i can even tell that it's being
hit
hello
and who's first who's first come on
you slow down a bit
you gotta tire yourself out
you slow down you slow down too
no i miss me
give me that
hello you want a hug
i got it i see it
i see it
you got any more big yellow spots that i
need to blow up
buddy
seriously what is this thing
more of them
a lot more of them
what you think you think you're a
challenge
whoa you're you didn't even turn blue
nope
nope
nope
nope thank you
is that all that was all
ah one more big yellow eye come here
come to papa
i'm gonna give you a nice tree hamburger
where'd you come from
i missed
how did i miss give me another marker
there's it
come on get over here
jesus you must have blinked you stupid
[ __ ]
yeah
hey i think i need that
harvard just hang on
i'm gonna have to pull you through his
gut
what
oh what carver was on that thing the
whole time oh okay
yeah
how am i doing that
oh
how did i do that
and gross
yeah ah they couldn't have come up with
a bigger enemy for me to fight
no more
[ __ ] here no
but earth
gets a tomorrow
um
isaac
you did it
you really did
earth space coordinates confirmed
shock drive enabled
standing by
no
no
oh
you got me oh
oh man
oh
i guess logically there's no way that
you can survive a moon landing on you
oh man oh
man
oh no
no
oh that poor guy
isaac clark
oh that poor guy
oh that sucks so bad
oh man
oh man
maybe there's an easter egg at the end
of the credits oh man but oh hang on i
gotta find usually they let you skip it
ah piss no they don't
oh man
that's crazy
oh it's insane i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna wait
i'm gonna wait so you guys are gonna i'm
gonna come back it's gonna skip ahead
for you i'm gonna come back at the end
of the credits so i'm gonna
i'm gonna sit here and wait
ellie
yeah that's what i'm talking about
that's why i wait i went to the end of
the crutch every time i play a game we
go
okay yeah oh
yeah yeah
i don't know how or how i don't care
he's alive he is freaking alive
he is alive
oh yeah ah yeah okay um before i close
this up i've got a lot of things that i
would like to say about the game um the
game itself was very very very good in
like two thumbs up couldn't recommend it
more it was incredibly fun as soon as i
got the mechanics down it was incredibly
balanced well done for hard and for how
much i'm used to playing dead space i
did very well so i'm going to try it on
impossible when i go alone next on maybe
if i can do a new game plus if not i'll
just do it on impossible anyway but
anyway that was really really
ridiculously awesome i love the story
and i love the dead space and i'm you
know it's kind of disappointing that
it's not as scary as before but when you
focus more on like
a a continuous story like this and you
want an epic conclusion that's kind of
got to build up to something so there
can't be a lot of just dark lonely
clustered because that's a smaller um
atmosphere to put yourself in and when
you've got this grand scale of a a
climactic conclusion you need a big epic
finish for games like this and not all
games need that i mean but this one it
was very fitting and i loved that they
had they probably listened to a lot of
people were like you didn't find a big
boss at the end of day space too and
they were like well can you get bigger
than that and it was like oh hell that
was freaking awesome loved every minute
of it um the only complaint i have about
the story that i didn't like is that
they weakened ellie as a character i
mentioned it while i was playing before
they weakened ellie as a character
because in dead space 2 when she was
introduced she was introduced as a self
uh independent badass who was k
perfectly capable of dismembering on her
own and in this entire game you didn't
see a gun in her hands once she was very
much relegated to the the um the the
damsel in distress role very much so
even at the end which was very cliche
and that she had to be rescued
even though they brought her back
arbitrarily she was just the um she was
the love interest in this one and i
don't think that was very fitting to her
role
but i guess it worked for the story and
somewhat they could have made her a bit
more badass i felt but that was my only
criticism other than that i recommend
everyone out there please play the game
buy it it's worth it go play it i i'm
gonna try co-op campaign with a friend
of mine and i'm gonna try the soul
campaign i'm gonna play this for hours
and hours and hours and it was an
incredible thing i hope you guys had a
great time watching i had a great time
playing it you know i i sometimes get
caught up in doing individual games that
i forget that i can do a long series and
it can have this big like worth it
payout like i wanted to compare it if i
thought that isaac was going to stay
dead i wanted to compare it to um mass
effect 3 and how shepherd's final push
you know i don't mind i don't mind if a
character dies if it's at the end of
this story but i mean with well the only
reason mass effect 3 was bad was not
because shepard died it was because
um it was mo it was solely because the
ending was so shoehorn this ending fit
if isaac died on that planet it would
have made sense
i wouldn't have wanted it to happen but
it would have been good for the story
when it's committed to the story and
works better for the story and it has to
be for the integration of the story
above all else it has to fit and work it
would have worked
and that he's alive i would love to see
how he got kept alive but i'm very happy
that he is
so i i i expect to see
a dead space 4. i'm very excited to see
a dead space 4 because they have not
finished where the markers came from
they we don't know
we don't know we don't know ah that's a
clerk will return okay so i'm excited i
will play any dlc that comes out by the
way so look forward to that
story driven dlc so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that i've done and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye